les pieds loin du sol la tête dans les
nuages là où on est tous égaux c'est ça
rêve de gosse des enfants ou parcours de
vie très différents partageant la même
expérience les mêmes sensations
c'est la première fois que j'ai fait
eva il y avait des sensations est vaste
pendant un an ces jeunes dits
extraordinaire et ordinaire ont appris à
se connaître autour d'un projet créatif
présenté aujourd'hui ce tour en avion et
leurs récompenses l'aboutissement de
l'aventuré c'est fabuleux c'est magique
c'est relate a été un beau travail de
collaboration entre mois entre écoles
donc c'est une belle berline dès
l'ouverture pour tous les jeunes se
soient des ailes vie que l'ordinaire
tout et s'y trouvait c'est exceptionnel
pour ses enfants ou ses merveilles et c1
un rêve de gosse vous appréhendez un peu
ou pas connus ray lawson pas du tout
les bénévoles sont bien rodés pour
l'accueil de ces jeunes parfois stressés
rêve de gosse est une action nationale
la 26e édition débute ici à dole avec
180 enfants de la région
pour les faire voler 23 équipages
composés de deux ou trois pilotes
souvent professionnelles comme etienne
et romain fidèles chaque année
faire plaisir à ses enfants et leur
donner du sourire et faire partager
notre passion qu'est l'aviation donc
c'est vraiment une très belle action
qu'on fait aujourd'hui et qu'on perdure
depuis plusieurs années maintenant c'est
des volontaires qui s'inscrivent qui
payent leurs heures de vol nous on en
remboursent uniquement les vols qui font
que les enfants mais toutes les vols de
transition d'une ville à l'autre c'est
eux qui les guident le paye notre
engagement civique et loisirs après dole
huit autres villes accueilleront les
bénévoles et leurs avions pour continuer
à faire rêver tous les enfants sans
faire de différence